someone's under there not my underoos
are fitting just fine thank you so why
is there a stick up your butt
stop making inquiries about my bottom
pan Julia mom and dad won't take me to
California to see Stephen Hawking you
thought they would take you to
California yes
they wouldn't even buy me this book at
the book fair I had to get it at the
library there's a booger on one of the
pages
well I may never get another chance to
see him in person suck it up
you always get everything you want
that's not true you got a computer I'm
reading a booger book fine how do you
recommend I suck it up I don't know we
don't get your way shut up and move on
it's not what you do
yeah and that's why you don't have a
computer
[Music]
dad you missed everything
well her George he lied the mom-to-be
loan in Jana's house but mom knew cuz
she listened it on his phone call boy
now he's grounded and everyone's mad not
me I'm super happy well bye dad
the University offered to pay for us to
go to California they're even putting us
up in a hotel kid we're going to
California no just me and Dad that's
fair
I'm so happy for you sometimes sarcasm
was late on so thick even I could detect
it
Thanks this was not one of those times
he found in like that you're gonna get
wrinkles like your meemaw you look great
I know I just want to hear you say it
what's on your mind one always gets
everything he wants yes he does that's
not fair ah no on the other hand he's
just going to some sighs lecture I know
me it's going on a plane to California
planes aren't all that great you can't
even smoke on them anymore I'll tell you
what after practice today you and me
will do something fun
come on my first cigarette No
can I get my ears pierced your mom won't
like that
so maybe
[Music]